I often get emails that say David is the
modern Republican party now fascist is
fascism what they would employ if there
were no barriers or opposition or
obstacles so let's explore this a little
bit and think it through and where I end
up coming down is that the modern
Republican Party
is a fascistic authoritarian party but
not actually fascist but part of the
reason why they are not actually fascist
is that there is opposition in the
United States so let's start with the
definition what are we talking about
when we talk about fascism fascism is a
far right
authoritarian political ideology which
often includes dictatorial power
forcible suppression of opposition and
very strongly regimented society and a
very strongly regimented economy now
some of these things might not sound
like the rhetoric of the Republican
party with strong regimentation the
Republican party is all about freedom
and liberty yes the rhetoric is but are
they actually like that when it comes to
policy so we're going to talk about that
what is the Republican Party platform
and policy
versus fascism or fascistic
authoritarianism because it is true that
it used to be the case that the
Republican party was known for
conservative values actually being for
small government promoting truly free
market capitalism or something close to
it but that is not at all what the
modern report modern Republican party
particularly under Mega trumpism has
become it has become a party of
hypernationalism
populist rhetoric
as well as extraordinarily overbearing
suppression of opposition all fascistic
characteristics and the bulk of this the
culmination of it has been seen in the
shift during the rise of Donald Trump
and his influence on the Republican
Party the rhetoric of trump and the
policies that trumpists would like to
implement are every combination of
authoritarian sometimes xenophobic
anti-competitive
Etc and we're going to look at a bunch
of examples the Muslim ban
family separation at the border trying
to overturn the 2020 presidential
election results trying to limit the
speech of the press and trying to get
adversarial reporters banned including
Jim Acosta Etc in addition to this
the attempt to suppress opposition
through election
meddling tactics that disproportionately
affect young people people of color
low-income individuals
disproportionately those who vote on the
left is another way in which Republicans
under Maga have tried to hold on to
Power by any means necessary even when
they've been voted out
completely anti-democratically now there
are people who will argue these are
straight up fascist tactics others say
it's kind of too extreme a term but it
is very hard to argue that it isn't
fascistic and Hardline authoritarianism
the actions and the rhetoric of Maga
trumpism aka the modern Republican party
have taken that bent so let's talk about
some of the specific policies and there
are so many but let's talk about a few
the Muslim ban one of the first things
that Donald Trump did as president
was signed an executive order Banning
travel from several Muslim majority
countries
it was done under the guise of
protecting the United States but it
targeted
muslim-majority countries that had not
actually been the sources of terrorism
to the United States you could make the
case that either way it was fascistic
but particularly when you're not even
targeting the quote right countries
based on what you claim to want to
achieve
discriminatory and absolutely
authoritarian so scale up of the
separation of families at the border the
zero tolerance policy at the southern
border which resulted in the separation
of families and the Detention of
children in cages inhumane cruel
emblematic of fascistic authoritarianism
the attacks on media Trump calling the
media fake news Trump's saying you can't
believe what you are hearing and seeing
you've got to listen to me to know the
truth enemy of the people get Jim Acosta
out of the White House Press briefing
room get adversarial media shut down
etc etc undermining Free Press which is
a Cornerstone of democracy voter
suppression
um pushing for uh voter ID of the kind
that would just make it harder for
people to vote uh shortening early
voting hours pushing for all of these
different things while claiming they are
trying to steal and cheat and Rob an
election
extraordinarily fascistic militarizing
the police Trump supported the use of
military equipment by police under the
guise of Law and Order
and that was an open attempt to suppress
dissident
protesters and those with views
adversarial to Trump embracing
authoritarian and dictatorial leaders
right I mean listen when you criticize
Canada and France and Germany Democratic
countries and you go I don't know I
believe Putin no matter what he says and
Kim Jong-un and I wrote each other love
letters and duterte has been very strong
on drugs and she does quick trials and
the death penalty for drug dealers and
bolsonaro and erdogan and Orban this is
another authoritarian fascistic Slide
the entire attempt to steal an election
Trump didn't win of course straight out
of the dictator's Playbook and then
lastly I would also point to
hardcore attempts to control private
entity private businesses for your
personal political gain and I'm thinking
of big Tech and social media
we don't want to uh we don't want to
regulate businesses unless it's
absolutely necessary businesses should
be allowed to regulate themselves and do
what they want except when we want to
force Twitter to publish Trump's
election lies covet this information and
on and on so bottom line
the modern Republican party may not fit
all of the characteristics of fascist
ideology and we certainly are not living
under fascism in the United States and
we weren't when Trump was President
either but there are elements of extreme
authoritarianism nationalism
right-wing populist rhetoric used to
justify some pretty hardcore policy and
it should concern all of us who worry
about this fascistic direction to the
American Republican party fascism no not
yet fascistic authoritarianism with some
dictatorial dreams 100 percent
plastic it's everywhere we look and not
enough is being done about it 100
billion plastic bags are used and thrown
away every year here's something super
simple you can do to reduce plastic and
help the planet a little bit our sponsor
hold on bags is the company making
plastic free trash bags and zip seal
kitchen bags they're just as strong and
high quality as the plastic bags you're
used to hold on bags are 100 percent
plant-based and home compostable meaning
they break down in just weeks not
decades their zip seal kitchen bags come
in sandwich or gallon size to fit all of
your needs whether it's carrots or
crayons at home I put all of my food
waste in a hold on trash bag throw it in
the compost pile and when I throw a hold
on trash bag in my dumpster I love
knowing it's not filling our landfills
and oceans with plastic single use
Plastics harm the planet at every Stage
production disposal decomposition join
the growing movement away from
single-use plastic these products are
really great it's so easy to make the
switch go to hold on bags.com
Pacman and you'll get 20 off with code
Pacman at checkout the link is down
below